[school bell ringing]
[funky hip-hop music]
- Oh!
all: Ooh!
Hey, how do my nuts taste?
[laughter]
- He should've walked away.
- Nice try, skeet scrub.
Now get to the back of the bus
with the rest of the shit crew.
[laughter]
- Class,
settle the fuck down.
Now as a part of our
"Scared Celibate" curriculum,
I will be partnering you up
to raise a goddamn baby.
- What you mean, raise a baby?
Can't we just go to
Planned Parenthood?
I got a coupon!
- How am I supposed to go league
if I got daddy responsibilities?
[all complaining]
- Oh, shut the fuck up!
I present to you
the Totbot 3000.
[Totbot 3000 coos]
Now for the next week,
you gotta pretend
this robot is
a motherfucking baby.
- [groans]
- Now it's time to
pair you bastards up.
Milk, you with Shamal.
- Man, I gotta boos
with this wank-ass...
Aight, I'ma be cool
'cause you my boy's sister,
but I gotta tell it like it is.
I ain't doin' 'nathen.
I'm keepin' it real,
like Grover's dad.
- That's fine,
as long as we're together.
- Jamal, I'm putting you
with Medina.
- [growls]
- Damn, Medina.
Can a ledge get
some breathing room?
You like a meat sweater.
- Don't get coy with me,
motherfucker.
We together,
so you better get used to
me gettin' up inside you.
- Cindy, I think
it'd be good for you
to be paired up with...Grover.
- Oh, word?
[classmates react]
- Come on, Coach.
You know Cindy and I
belong together.
She's my lady.
- Nice try, motherfucker,
but we've got our first game
this week.
We don't need you sticking
your energy in the wrong place.
So your partner is LaDante.
We progressive
like a motherfucker.
[laughter]
- Brandy, you gonna be
my wife for life.
On Oakland.
[smooches, slurps]
- No!